يدل اسم حميه البحر المتوسط الغذائيه على
كونها نظام غذائي مستمد من الاطعمه التي
يتناولها ابناء البلدان التي تشاطئ البحر
الابيض المتوسط الحميه المتوسطيه تختلف من
الدول المتوسط لكنها بشكل عام تعتمد على
نظام غذائي غني بالخضروات والفواكه
والاسماك وتشمل ايضا البقوليات والمكسرات
والدهون غير المشبعه مثل زيت الزيتون
وكميات منخفضه من اللحوم ومنتجات الالبان
الدراسات الطبيه اظهرت ان هذه الحميه حميه
البحر المتوسط تقلل من خطر الاصابات
بامراض القلب نظرا لكونها تعتمد بشكل كامل
على نظام منخفض الكوليسترول الضار
الدراسات رابطه بشكل قوي بين الحميه
المتوسطيه وانخفاض معدل الوفيات وذلك بسبب
امراض القلب والاوعيه الدمويه كذلك فان
هذه الحميه تساعد على الوقايه من سرطان
الثدي بنسبه للسيده
[موسيقى]